we'll talk about your writing which uh I
I would highly recommend people read in
just the letters to
shareholders uh so you wrote up uh
explaining the idea of day one thinking
I think you first wrote about in 97
letters to shareholders then you also in
a way wrote it
about sad to say is your last letter sh
coo um and you've said that day two is
stasis followed by
irrelevance followed by excruciating
painful decline followed by death and
that is why it's always day
one um can you explain this day one
thing this is a really powerful way to
describe the beginning and the journey
of Amazon it's it's really a very simple
and I think age old idea about renewal
and rebirth and like every day is day
one every day you're deciding what
you're going to do and you are not
trapped by what you were or who you were
or any self-consistency self-consistency
even can be a trap and so day one
thinking is kind of we start fresh every
day and we get to make new decisions
every day about invention about
customers about uh how we're going to
operate what even even even as deeply as
what our principles are we can go back
to that turns out we don't change those
very often but we change them
occasionally and um when we work
on programs at
Amazon we often uh make a list of
tenants and this the tenants are kind of
they're not principles they're a little
more tactical than principles but it's
kind of the the main
ideas that we want this program to
embody whatever those are and one of the
things that we do is we put these are
the tenants for this program and in
parenthesis we always put unless you
know a better
way and that idea unless you know a
better way is so important because you
never want to get trapped by Dogma you
never want to get trapped by history
doesn't mean you discard history or
ignore it there's so much value in what
has worked in the past and but you can't
be blindly following what you've done
and that's the heart of day one is
you're always starting fresh and uh to
the question of how to fend off day two
you said such a question can't have a
simple answer as you're saying there
will be many elements multiple paths and
many traps I don't know the whole answer
but I may know bits of it here's a
starter pack of Essentials maybe others
come to mind for day one
defense customer Obsession uh a
skeptical view of proxies the eager
adoption of external trends in High
Velocity decision making so we talked
about High Velocity decision making
that's more difficult than it
sounds so maybe you can pick one that
stands out to you as you can comment on
uh eager adoption of external trends
High Velocity decision-making skeptical
view of proxies how do you fight off day
two well you know I'll talk about
because I think it's the one that is
maybe in some ways the hardest to
understand um is the skeptical view of
proxies um one of the things that
happens in business probably anything
that you're where you're you know you
have an ongoing program and something is
is underway for a number of years is you
develop certain things that you're
managing to like let's say the typical
case would be a metric
and that metric isn't the real
underlying
thing and so uh you know maybe the
metric is um efficiency metric around
customer contacts per unit sold or
something like if you sell a million
units how many customer contacts do you
get or how many returns do you get and
so on and so on and so what happens is a
little bit of a kind of inertia sets
in where somebody long time ago invented
that metric and they invented that
metric they decided we need to watch for
you know customer returns per unit sold
as an important metric but they had a
reason why they chose that metric the
person who invented that metric and
decided it was worth watching and then
fast forward five years that metric is
the proxy MH the proxy for truth I guess
the proxy for truth the proxy for custo
let's say in this case it's a proxy for
customer
happiness and but that metric is not
actually customer happiness it's a proxy
for customer happiness the person who
invented the metric understood that
connection five years
later a kind of inertia can set in and
you
forget the truth behind why you were
watching that metric in the first place
and the world shifts a little yeah and
now that proxy isn't as viable as it
used to be or it's missing something and
you have to be on alert for that you
have to know okay this is I don't really
care about this metric I care about
customer
happiness and this metric is
worth putting energy into and following
and improving and scrutinizing only in
so much as it actually affects customer
happiness and so you got to constantly
be on guard and it's very very comp this
is a nuanced problem it's very common
especially in large companies that they
are managing to metrics that they don't
really understand they don't really know
why they exist and the world may have
shifted out from under them a little and
the metrics are no longer as relevant as
they were when somebody 10 years earlier
invented the
metric that is a Nuance but uh that's a
big problem right there's something so
compelling to have a nice metric to try
to optimize yes and by the way you do
need metrics yes you do you know you
can't ignore them um you want them but
you just have to be constantly on guard
this is you know a a way to slip into
day two thinking would be to manage your
business to metrics that you don't
really understand and you're not really
sure why they were invented in the first
place and you're not sure they're still
as relevant as they used to
be
that